I'm really pressed to ask leaders around
the world this question okay how about
our now what do you think about the
although everybody in terms of
socioeconomic status is slowly coming up
and everyone slowly coming up
exponential technology is causing a very
very sharp increase for the very wealthy
right now what do we do about the lower
middle class you know it that's that's a
really tough situation because if you
think about it
human beings power is not something that
you know as long as the markets are free
and as long as you're free to do
whatever whoever has the dominant
position that's its currency or whether
it's technology or whether its brains to
create stuff there's always going to be
these you know people who have an
advantage because they know how to gain
the system and think about what's
happening what happened in the financial
situation Bernie Madoff and all those
scams
I actually have no idea how we going to
solve those because as long as human
beings have differences they're going to
be differences you know I don't know how
to take care of that it's going to be a
really different people will tell you
they know the answers but I think they
don't know they're nobody can know this
answer this is why we asked it because
people give very interesting solutions
to the problem that are part of the full
solution and then maybe we can glue
together some of the pieces for a pretty
good one but you said as long as there
is the the differences it's very
difficult to find something
maybe if the overall basic needs of the
hierarchy were filled to a point where
we were all just then able to focus on
purpose or focus on meaning then then at
that point at least because then there
still needs to be some room for
innovation and creativity for people to
have an incentive for it so this is this
complication then there's the
globalization complication to the wealth
and equality conversation and now we're
talking about what's like the most nutty
thrilling artificial general
intelligence and this well when you
think about this okay when the internet
came along the idea was to give access
to everyone equal access that's why it
was free right when you think about it
like that
people started you know you got lot of
you just user-generated content I can't
even remember the last number of
websites created by people I think it
was in the billions or something I might
be completely wrong I don't remember
very high very high like that right but
how many of those actually get any
people right so when you think about it
which sites I mean think about Google
and Amazon and Apple and Facebook and so
again the people that kind of have the
knowledge the wherewithal and the
ability to gain that system in whatever
way behavioral economics and you know
all that so the ones that kind of are
the first movers and that tend to get
the uptake and so again when we try to
kind of democracy democratize something
it doesn't work because it can't be that
everyone has equal equality equal
outcome yeah yeah so so then it is like
the
it's like the global conversation around
the people that have the most power is
needs to happen and we need to figure
out how to have that conversation okay
so if you come across this solution
remember to send it to me if I hate I
will spend a whole lifetime trying to
inspire people to have the conversation
and we probably will come close to
figuring out a part of the solution only
you